what does Riz mean oh RZ that's Riz is
short for Charisma kind of like Charisma
right that's the second person that said
that we've only had two people it's like
Charisma it's like you got that
Riz first of all isn't it Charisma like
oh my mean r is kind of like kind of
means like
Charisma five times in a row you're the
fifth person who said that and we've had
five people do you have R like get
what's your best pick of L the thing is
my RZ is on on such a level that I don't
need to be pull cuz they're already
pulling me you know like I just got to
walk you have no RZ my Riz needs no
words is what I'm trying to say like I
like I come in and you know